[Music]  you know the uh the situation from mtv's  jersey shore was a guest on our show  last night we have  a monitor right here  where the guests can see themselves on  camera and you know we're sitting over  there but you can see this monitor is  right off to the side and i was amazed  at the number of times he checked  himself out on the television monitor  in front of his chair okay  i think he set a world record take a  look i mean situation  situations  situations okay sich  i got to talk to you thanks for being  here  when the whole thing was starting to  and you i was complimenting you because  you came up with a nickname which i  think is genius  uh the situation and you gave me a  nickname yes  the solution yes  that was good  which was genius that was a good  nickname yeah i mean because the  solution i mean you could pretty much  solve any equations  yeah yeah  [Applause]